انا الطفله كنز احمد
الزهارنه مواليد
2011 احنا نزحنا عند خالتي في دير البلح
فجاه يوم من الايام ايش اجانا خبر انه
برنا القصه راحت العابه راحت تختي تحت
غرفي
ومدينتنا اللي كانت قبل 7 اكتوبر
احلى ومدرستي انهدمت برضه ف فيش شي ضير
لنا احنا نازحين عند خالتي خالتي عند
المحكمه الشرعيه خالتي يعني يا دوبها
تكفين فوق ال 50 نفر وكل هدول الانفار
اطفال اطفال يعني فش يعني يا دوبها توسعنا
يمكن 80 متر او اقل يعني يعني بننام واحنا
يمكن خمسه جن في فرشه واحده او في فرشتين
يعني ما بنعرفش ننام مره كنت نايمه صحيت
على صوت دبه طلعت الجيران وقصفت وبتكسر كل
ازاز واحنا عند خالتي مش في دارنا احنا
دارنا خص الازاز تقصر فيش نا شوادر حتى
عشان نحط شي غطي لهذا عشان ايش ننام وحنا
مش مثلجين ف بننام كل ما بدي اجي انام او
اخفى بتصير دبه كل ما اجي اخفى بتصير دبه
يعني احنا بالليل بنعرفش الناس احنا بس
يطلع الصبح بحكي الحمد لله انه طلع الصبح
لانه الليل كثير
مرعب
ان